foreign
[Music]
is a town unlike anywhere you've ever
seen
[Music]
a town whose story is inextricably
intertwined with our lives
untold story about the consequences of
the 21st century economy
this
is
the chuki kamata mine
more than a century old more than a
kilometer deep
and you just saw it getting even deeper
High explosives blasting another
enormous hole in the bottom of this the
biggest man-made hole in the world and
all to satisfy our insatiable demand
for copper
1 in 12 of every atom of copper we have
ever extracted from the earth came from
here
there's a good chance there's some of it
in the device you're watching this on
but this is really a story about
something bigger than just copper
it is a story about scale
about how our hunger for natural
resources is already reshaping the world
because if we are to satisfy our demand
for copper for wind turbines and solar
panels and electric cars we will need to
build another three of these mines every
single year
and because you have to move many tons
of Earth to extract even a small amount
of copper that means we'll have a look
the waste rock from the mine is slowly
burying the town of chuki kamata
somewhere underneath this pile is what
was once the most advanced hospital in
South America
this ghost town is preserved more or
less as they left it a few years ago
when the Rocks began to swallow it up
there's lots of abandoned towns around
the world there's nothing quite like
this one this used to be the Old Town
Square and you can see there was a
social club over there there's a bank a
theater an indoor gymnasium apparently
the first indoor gymnasium uh in Chile
and over here this obviously was a
playground there's a slide there's a
model of Pinocchio and Beyond it is one
of the main schools in town and you can
see the roof has fallen in and some of
the murals have been exposed that the
children clearly used to enjoy but
overshadowing everything is that
enormous mound of rubble and that
basically is the explanation for why
this place is so empty and so desolate
the other reason they left the town was
toxic fumes from the refinery most of
the community moved to nearby Kalama 10
miles away but even there residents
worry that the air wafting down from the
mine is causing serious consequences
like most residents Andrea comes from a
mining family everyone here makes their
living out of copper so few speak out
she is one of the exceptions
Allied
is arsenico is
kadalco which runs the mine to kind to
comment
but the people here are fighting an
Unstoppable Force
and since electric cars need double or
even three times the copper you get in a
petrol car the holes get even deeper
here in a neighboring pit mining the
same vein the diggers keep digging and
the trucks keep lugging the ore and
waste rock up from the hole 24 hours a
day 365 days a year
after it's refined the pure metal is
piled high on trains and prepared for
export
and this is a part of that hidden
infrastructure upon which we all rely
getting the copper down from the
mountain through here to the port and
onto ships so that it can come to Europe
and the rest of the world
and alongside the tracks which carry
this Precious Cargo
a reminder that this is one of the most
unequal countries in the world
after mining the biggest political issue
is the gap between haves and have-nots
they say
oil and as we Electrify everything to
reach Net Zero and reduce our Reliance
on fossil fuel States these are the
exports we all rely on
and if copper is the new oil perhaps
that makes chili the new Saudi Arabia
Chile
[Music]
S Services
but this is not just a land of copper
and lithium
it is a place of Haunting Beauty
[Music]
of unique ecosystems of animals living
in fragile harmony with their
surroundings
in a desert where it hardly ever rains
[Music]
this is the Salah de Atacama one of the
world's biggest Salt Flats
a vast expanse underneath which of vast
riches
here in one of the world's most extreme
environments beneath this thick crust of
salt caked with sand it's the world's
biggest Reserves
of lithium that crucial material that
goes into pretty much all rechargeable
batteries and is going to help us to
reduce our reliance on fossil fuels
more than a quarter of the world's
lithium comes from here much of it mined
by a local company called sqm
but this is a very different kind of
mining to extracting copper
it is mining an ancient underground
reservoir of brine concentrated salt
water
this is the first moment that Brian has
seen the sun in millions of years
and over months in these enormous pools
the Desert Sun slowly evaporates the
water leaving this
this green yellow liquid is one of the
most important substances in the world
[Music]
funny isn't it I think that one of the
most advanced forms of technology these
days rechargeable state-of-the-art
batteries begin their life with that
glugging noise over there as that
concentrated brine solution is pumped
through from that pond over to this one
look you can see it coming out there now
that
is about 25
lithium chloride that is going to go
into your smartphone battery or your
electric car thank you
okay wow it's really yellow oh it's very
yellow green yeah very concentrated very
if you had the chance to touch it it's
uh oily okay so it looks like a taste
feels like oil because it's so and the
viscosity is so high
it's a special place this place then oh
definitely yes these are the special
condition for the solar to form these
mountains Falls volcanic rocks water and
perfect condition for evaporation so our
arid places
in the Arid Hills and Villages above the
Salah water and money are scarce
the people here look down at those great
pools that hint of great riches and warn
of great damage
Pamela's family has lived here as long
as anyone can remember but now as the
outside world pushes for more and more
resources their way of life is under
threat is
foreign
the miners admit they're using water but
they deny it has any effect on the
villagers supplies even so you cannot
escape the compromises here
and as we buy more electric cars with
all their batteries it means more demand
for what comes out of the sqm refinery
on the edge of the desert where they
process that yellow brine into battery
grade lithium
they call this white gold
there's enough in this Warehouse alone
for 40 000 electric cars
and with lithium prices at record highs
it is worth many millions of pounds
but how to balance this profit against
the environmental losses
for as the world looks towards Chile for
all these materials its new government
is drafting new rules which could
constrain production
s
and in what they hope will Mark a new
political Dawn the country is rewriting
its Constitution which also means more
controls on mining biologist Christina
dorador is among the authors it's a big
Paradox in the middle of the Atacama
Desert where this is the driest desert
of the war
The Wharf study there have been a
decrease in in Flamingo population in
the in the last 10 years a circle of 12
percent of the flamingo population have
decreased it's impossible to live
without mining we need materials of
course but the scale is huge and it's
affecting a long-term Oracle systems
sqm disputes that analysis but makes no
bones about what it is doing there is no
human activity without any impact we are
causing an impact here yes but the key
is to keep that impact under control
mitigate the risk so it is mining yes
the alternative is just doing nothing
but you need that material you're gonna
get that material from one place or
another
as the world pushes towards net zero
replacing fossil fuels with wind and
solar power
electrifying everything
the demand for the materials they have
in this country will only intensify
and so too will the compromises
[Music]
and the question marks
as pristine environments
untouched since the dawn of humanity
face a new age of mineral exploitation
[Music]